So that was the original
condensation paper.
Like I said, it was in 98.
There have been many versions subsequent
things that have to do with importance
sampling, that look at the particles and
stuff.
Here's another example of
doing head tracking, 2002.
And you can see,
it's still a hard white right there,
tracking the head there, kay?
There's an interesting
example right here.
You see the head here is fully visible,
but then it goes behind the cabinet.
In fact, the only part of the head
that's visible I just outlined,
in fact,
only the top half is visible there.
So the question is,
how did they move through occlusion?
Okay?
because part of the head is missing.
Well, maybe they used velocity in
their state or maybe they didn't.
What do you think?
You think they did or
you think they didn't?
Personally, I would have thought they
did because, I mean, I know all about
common filter and I know if you
track velocity it's real easy, but
then if I think about particle filters,
I say I probably didn't need
to track velocity for
the following reason.
It's not the case that it has to be
a great example of a head contour.
It has to be the case that the example
of the head contour that's here
is a better example than if I
put the head somewhere else.
And in fact, indeed, this paper,
they track the head through the,
the partial occlusion without velocity.
Now, would it have worked if the head
was totally occluded behind the cabinet?
No.
Because then the thing would
just stay there in fact they,
they call it a velocity zero model.
The particles just
stay where they are and
they just defuse out
from the uncertainty.
And so if you showed up on
the other side of the cabinet,
you'd be out of the frame
of view altogether.
Yes, Megan, I'm back, okay.
Where as, if you did velocity, you would
follow me, follow me, there you go,
follow, very, very good.
So now you get the, you get the point.